i want to introduce a new notion or a
notion i've been working on recently and
maybe you can help me with it
i'm not entirely satisfied with it but
i'm
more satisfied with it than some people
and it goes like this if what we are
caught in
see my problem was always i saw this
tremendous transformation
ahead of us but i always
as strong as my intuition of the
transformation
was also my resistance to the miraculous
so that i didn't want the transformation
to be
that ships the size of new jersey
come from the galactic center and appear
over every city on earth
or that atlantis rises
from beneath the waves and the crystal
tablets
reveal the correct agenda or i
i always thought that these things were
sort of hokey
and so as a rationalist as an
ex-catholic
i was trying to imagine
the incorporeal essence walking around
on city streets and
and how could that happen well the clue
was given to me recently when i was
asked to review
a book that hasn't been published yet
but will be
soon and i urge you all to get it it's
just a
hoot end of mine
um nick herbert
the outlaw physicist as he loves to call
himself
and the book if it's titled as
tentatively titled
will be called faster than light and it
was sent to me by the publisher so i
would say something nice about it and
and they would put it on the back and he
did
i'm a connoisseur of faster than light
schemes as probably most of us were when
we were 14 years old and
let me tell you this guy has dug up
stuff you have
never heard of uh it's not the old
mini is in a ship a maxi is in ship b
they pass each other each going the same
no it's much better than that
but one of the things that he talked
about was the feasibility
of time machines and
i uh have always
been interested in
the the mandayan cosmology
which mandayans are a sect
that arose probably around jerusalem
somewhere in the early christian era
they claim they were founded by john the
baptist
but who knows but anyway they can be
traced back to that milieu
and over the centuries they've had many
wanderings and peregrinations and
settled eventually probably to their
regret
in the swamps of iraq and iran some
three centuries ago and what
shape they are in in the aftermath of
this war
i have not heard i have no idea perhaps
they're extinct it cannot have been a
happy
experience for them but anyway a very
rich
very old tradition and they have the
notion in their cosmology
of a messiah which they call the secret
adam
and the secret adam will come at the end
of the world
and the mandayan notion of what's going
on
is that we all have a soul made of light
and the light is trapped in matter
this universe is not our home this
universe is a
a kind of hell in which we wander
and the purpose of religion is to teach
people about the light inside themselves
and how to gather it together and how to
get it out of this universe uh and into
our rightful home which is a much better
place
okay so the mandayan uh uh
eschaton is that
this messiah called the secret adam will
come
but what's unusual is that the secret
adam
teaches no message has
no point of view but
builds a machine they specifically say
this
builds an object of some sort
and the object operationally could be
described as
a light pump the light pump
of the mandayan messiah then gathers
the light of all souls that have lived
or
are living and transmits
the light first to the sun
no first to the moon then to venus
then to the sun and then out of this
universe entirely to the higher
and hidden presence of the all father
well this is very interesting especially
to me
because i have very deeply ingrained in
me
the idea that these messianic scenarios
these end of the world scenarios
are visions of future events
being picked up by various holy seers
men and women of great depth
of inner vision and the mandayan one to
my mind is the only one
that specifically mentions the building
of an object rather than a moral
reform of some sort so i want to put out
to you
a notion that is definitely embryonic
but promising and the idea came to me
from nick herbert's book
although just a few lines and rip him to
the bone
but he he asked the question he wants to
talk about time machines and the first
question he asks is
well uh obviously if time travel
were to be discovered at any point in
the future
uh how come we don't see time travelers
why aren't they coming and going
myself tell me and let me see if you got
it right
because just like there are
waveforms and currents and eddies in the
ocean or something
uh this particular time we're in
historical time
is a time in in which uh time machines
don't seem to work too well
but time before this and after this
maybe they work quite well so people go
back and forth but
they can't go through this part because
it's the wrong kind of current
b plus close
well that's the paranoid theory
[Music]
that in fact there are time machines and
if you only knew
where to look or who to ask you would
find that they're whizzing by
but this gentleman comes much closer to
it and you'll love the simplicity of
this i hope
the reason we don't see time machines
coming and going
is because we live in an era
before time machines
and no time machine can go back in time
earlier than the moment of the invention
of the first time machine
so i had never considered this before
and found it very interesting and so i
i uh tried to imagine
what would it then be like to be
involved
in the invention of the first time
machine because as you know when we were
in the amazon in 1971
we attempted to build what we called a
trans-dimensional vehicle
and we stressed that it would be
basically a spaceship because we're
spatial monkeys and that was how we
thought of it
but if you're really going to make good
on a trans-dimensional vehicle you also
have to have a gear
which takes you not to our tourists but
to yesterday
and so
i i tried to envision what
this
moment of constructing and launching the
first time machine would be like
and i came up with a scenario something
like this
it's late december of 2012 a.d
and at the
world temporal studies institute on the
banks of the agar aparana
in central amazonas technicians are
putting the final touches
on the first time machine
and the chief
scientist chosen to pilot the time
machine
into the future is just donning her
time suit and being escorted to the
cockpit
and the hatches are being closed and the
system checked out
finally everything is perfect just
as dawn begins to break
over the jungle the button is pushed
and this woman
sails off into the future
and there have been no prototypes there
have been
no partial mock-ups no problem tests
because in the nature of the thing it
just can't be done that way
now mike my question most people i think
at this point would want to know
would want to follow this woman's career
what does she see as she moves off into
the future
and and what paradoxes does it generate
my concern was not with that i wish her
luck
and turn my attention elsewhere
specifically
back to the laboratory
i wanted to know what happens at that
moment
and the first thing that occurred to me
was
it seemed obvious suddenly all over the
earth
time machines will appear
coming from all sectors of the future
why because they want to see the first
voyage into time they want to be present
at this momentous event it's as if you
had an airplane that could travel in
time
well this is a mixed metaphor but
wouldn't you
fly to kitty hawk to be there to see
the first powered flight of a of a of an
aircraft so at first i imagined that
the skies and freeways of earth would
fill
with travelers coming from the far
future to
to explore the membrane but because
that's
the end of the road for time travelers
they can't go further back because
before that moment
time machines were impossible and didn't
exist
and i was troubled by this
little science fiction scenario and i
couldn't quite put my finger on what the
problem
was and then as i smoked more
i realized that the problem was
that in what is the undoing of all
time travel scenarios is the what's
called the kill your own grandfather
paradox
this is very simply stated and i'm sure
familiar to most of you
if time travel were possible i could go
back in time
and shoot my grandfather if i shoot my
grandfather
i my mother is never born therefore i am
never born therefore how could i go back
in time and shoot my grandfather
i couldn't therefore time travel is
impossible
and i realized that in the kind of
scenario i've just described to you
the grandfather paradox would come into
play
because someone in uh century
eight after time travel
century eight att
could go back to century 7
18 and kill their grandfather and
therefore not
exist and therefore set the paradox in
motion
so i ruminated on this problem
and finally i understood or i at least
had the illusion
of understanding how to resolve
this paradox and how to solve a whole
bunch of problems that i hadn't realized
were even associated with what i was
thinking about
and it is this
and i'm going to now make a spatial
metaphor about a temporal
situation i want you to to think of
um today the present world
situation where we have
rain forest very
you know pre-literate rain forest hunter
gatherer
cultures on the same planet as los
angeles and tokyo existing in the same
temporal moment
well now what's happening in the modern
world
isn't what is happening and rather
quickly
is that the accomplishments values
attitudes and
desires of the people of tokyo los
angeles
and manhattan are completely swamping
all other values the rainforest indian
doesn't want to be a better shaman
he wants better reception on his
transistor radio
the rainforest shaman doesn't want to
learn how to make fish traps he wants to
learn how to repair hondas
what is happening in the world today
is that the values of the most advanced
cultures
are completely swamping
and eclipsing all other values and i
think that this would happen
in a in a world where time travel were
possible so that
this has a very odd effect
now let's go back to our scenario at
dawn of 2012
a.d we send our lady tempo knot
off into the future and a micro
second later what happens is not
the appearance of time travelers from
all areas of the future
what happens a moment later is the
appearance
all over the earth of the most
advanced state possible
within the complete set of the entire
future
in other words if human develop
culminates 10 million years in the
future in some kind of
unimaginable biomechanical
transcendental erratic
apocalypse of some sort or apotheosis of
some sort
that state will immediately appear on
the other side of the membrane
a microsecond after the first person
moves off
into the future in other words the
discovery of time travel
ends history forever
and there is no history in effect
inventing this kind of time travel will
cause the entirety of the future
to happen instantly it will undergo
some kind of compression in the same way
that time
and matter undergo a compression toward
infinity
inside the black hole so what
this means if we can take it
seriously even as a metaphor is
that if if a whey were found
to transfer information into the future
and if time travel works in such a way
that information then from the future
could be transferred into the past
as far as the moment of the invention
of the first time machine then what you
effectively have
is all the resources
of the entire future history
of our species coming available to us
a millisecond after we invent
this kind of a device it is
a perfect and extreme example of what i
call the forward escape
it's that we it's essentially a siren
we're building a siren which calls
the resources of future humanity
millions and millions of years in the
future
into the late 20th century or early 21st
century
uh historical situation and it does it
without the intervention of flying
saucers
without the violation of natural law
without the summoning of galactic
ecologists
to come in flying sauces it explains
then it is the it is the generation of
the perfect
tool it explains how the cultural
process
of tool making ends in its own
uh self-transcendence and i
and if you're wondering what does this
have to do with psychedelics and
shamanism
well what it has to do with it is that
in the same way in quantum physics as
you get virtual
tunneling where a particle appears
mysteriously on the other side of an
energy barrier
without ever having acquired enough
energy to pass over the barrier
so that it's said that it tunneled back
i think
information from this hyper
temporal domain
beyond the end of history a very small
amount
of this information tunnels backward
naturally as a as a kind of leaky
process and that this is what shamanism
and religious sensitivity and poetry and
everything that characterizes our
humanism
is about we are quite literally
that animal that can sense the future
and being able to sense it over the past
hundred thousand years we have gone in
search of it
in the same way that an animal can smell
water
on the wind and can then go
in search of water and eventually find
the water hole
because of our large brain capacity
because information is a quantum
mechanically expressed
state in the brain we can
smell the future and have been able to
do so
for 50 60 000 years
and i think the the thing which
amplifies
this state are the psychedelic plants
this is how the boundary dissolving
works that i've taught all of these
things have to be seen in
more and more and more concrete terms
these are not metaphors when we say the
psychedelic dissolves
boundaries we're not only talking about
boundaries like between you and me
we're talking about boundaries like
between past and future
so the shamanic vision is actually
uh an anticipation
of the future state of the human species
and and as uh
where we can make several kinds of
metaphors since we don't know what this
information bearing particle is which
runs backward against the continuum of
time
we can hypothesize that it
encounters resistance so that
as you approach
it let's call it the waterhole or
hyperspace
there is more and more information about
it
so that the shaman getting loaded a
hundred thousand years ago
has only the faintest flickering
intimation of
something and the shaman getting stoned
10
000 years ago says you know there's more
of it
it's getting clearer i can feel it i can
taste it
and the shaman getting stoned now just
has to hold his or her head
and stand the intensity of this
wind of information blowing out of
hyperspace and carrying with it
an image of the transcendence of
of our species and the strange thing is
that
human decisions human acts
will determine when we enter into this
domain
as a fully realized cultural artifact
it is the philosopher's stone which
informed the mystical visions of the
16th century
they were that close to it
and now we are so close to it that we
not only encounter
it in dreams and in drug states but
under certain conditions of isolation
and not even isolation
we see it in the sky we see machines
apparently made of matter in the sky
this is what the ufo
is it is an intimation of the future
history of humanity haunting the skies
of earth
like an image and so as we approach this
singularity
and i for reasons that are mathematical
and too complex
to lay out here i accept the end of the
mayan calendar the december 22nd 2012
date and think that's a very reasonable
end date to assign to this process
and what we must do is create
metaphors so that we understand this and
i feel that's what my
uh function is is to talk about this
information
flowing out of the future and try and
create
metaphors linguistic nets that
can hold it because to the degree that
we can
assure ourselves and communicate among
ourselves that this is happening we can
lose
some of our anxiety about what is
happening to
our species and this planet i mean we
are involved in the execution of an
extremely
complex acrobatic performance i mean
this is
you know the triple backflip and
uh there is risk and there is tension
but i believe that the information
flowing
into our heads through the amplification
of these psychedelic molecules
tells us that we do succeed we will
succeed it is accomplished and that
is the thread which holds it all
together so we need not
doubt we need not fear we need
merely to trim our edges to participate
more smoothly in the process whose
eventual success
we are already receiving intimation of
we all or it's generally agreed i think
that there is this compression
going on that everything is being more
densely connected more densely expressed
well if you draw the if you
again to use the black hole model that
what happens in the center of a black
hole is
that matter becomes infinitely
compressed well the term infinitely
compressed
doesn't mean anything so then what
astrophysicists
say is well there must then be in
another universe
a white hole and the matter in the
center of the black hole
spurts into this other universe and
begins to define a new
topology well if with what's happening
to us
is a kind of cultural convergence on
infinite density
well then at some point
to avoid becoming a tautology or to
avoid
generating a contradiction the
information will simply begin to expand
into another dimension in other words it
will have filled
this dimension and yet there's still
more stuff
coming in so it has to go somewhere
so then like the matter breaking out and
defining a new topology like a white
hole
it breaks out and begins to fill
the future so you have not exactly time
travel but just simply the need to
generate another dimension a dimension
orthogonal to the axes of all the
other dimensions that you were
previously
and this is what happens when a system
complexifies
beyond a certain point beyond the point
where it can be described
then you say then a formalist would say
well there are additional
dimensions therefore we have to add
additional descriptive vectors
and we can add as many of these
descriptive vectors as there are
dimensions
needing describing in fact the formal
understanding of what a dimension is is
simply a variable
it's not mysterious you know you can
have a 23-dimensional system
if you have 23 variables there is a
language
problem here because our language is not
designed to deal with this stuff
our language assumes but one let me say
one more thing about singularities
most theories require them and then it's
how you handle it that determines how
graceful the theory is
the current uh quote-unquote orthodox
paradigm
is what's called and i'm sure you know
all about it the big
bang model and this asks you to believe
in one major singularity
it occurs be at the very instant the
first
thing that happens is a singularity
and the universe springs from
nothingness the entire universe
all that we can see all that we cannot
see
is at in this stage considerably smaller
than a dime
in fact considerably smaller than a dime
it is the diameter of a proton
and and then there is and once you
grant this extremely unlikely
section then the laws of physics
can be plugged in and this thing expands
and light all these things happen but
this is a tremendous unlikelihood
this springing of the universe from
nothing it in fact
differs not at all from the first words
of genesis you know
in the beginning was the word i mean let
there be light it is
a complete fita complee
a complete deus ex machina
intercession it is just it happens
don't ask why all consequences proceed
from it it is the primary fact their
questions can be asked about it in terms
of metaphysical questions
well my notion is that
singularities are possible
but it would seem to me they are more
likely
in complex situations
rather than simple situations and the
situation before the universe existed
is the simplest situation
that it is possible to conceive of
no time no space no energy
no matter no topological manifold of any
so in other words
a a nothingness that would make a
buddhist
blush precedes this
so it is you know it is the the simplex
as they call it an alchemy it is the
simplest of the simple well how the hell
out of that situation are you supposed
to have a universe of the size and
complexity of ours
spring for no reason seems to me
far more likely that if you're going to
get a singularity
it's going to be in a universe filled
with complexity of every level of every
kind all kinds of radiation
all kinds of coding systems all kinds of
molecular systems all kinds of
self-reflecting animal life
all kinds of self-propagating
plants in other words a universe rather
like our own
this is the kind of universe where
it's possible something completely
astonishing could emerge and then after
it had emerged and was fully documented
then people would say well of course you
realize the background situation was so
complex
that we should have expected something
like this
and and so i would be more comfortable
with placing a singularity
like the philosopher's stone the
hypothetical time machine the emergence
into
hyperspace in in a very very complex
situation and i think that the situation
we're
in is the most complex we know of
and it's getting more complex all the
time
and rapidly so i think that indicates
that we are
caught locked in in the gravitational
field if you will or the the novelty
field
of an immensely novel object of some
sort that lies ahead of us
on the temporal axis and that what we
call history is the deepening
tug on a primate species
of a singularity which over a hundred
thousand years
is going to take that primary primate
species
whip it through a phase of historical
development that will deepen and deepen
and complexify and then finally inject
it
into a modality completely different
from anything
that it's ever known and to the degree
that we can raise this process to
consciousness
we can shed our anxiety
shed our masculine ego
because the masculine ego does not
believe this
this story that i've told you this
morning it's a it's
humdrum cut and dried kill or be killed
lay in your food for the winter hold
down the dreaming
uh you know but keep away from the large
metaphors try and stay with the here and
now
sharpen your blades keep your powder dry
so forth and so on but the boundary
dissolution
that we all can experience by submitting
ourselves to the
a temporal information bank of the
planet
which is what the psychedelics are the
antenna to
the markov genetic fields of the planet
past
present and future are what are being
transmitted
out of the vegetable matrix and into
animal life and animal life is a kind of
being lost in time
a kind of victimized state
i mean it's the prey for modality it's
the price
we pay for having such a complex sexual
process that we cannot just propagate
ourselves
by cutting off an arm and putting it in
the ground and having it grow into a
person
we have instead a very complex and
different kind of strategy
that makes us extremely focused
on what we call the present moment
makes us extremely uh fearful
about the future and extremely
prone to forget to the past
are we making an assumption here that
time and history
are linear and fixed it seems like you
could
you wouldn't have the the paradox of the
grandfather feeling
if let's say some the time travel is
possible and you go
in uh for the past and kill your
grandfather uh
but time isn't it isn't fixed and linear
that there would be a different
path happen and the fact that there
wouldn't
just a whole concept where there
wouldn't be a paradise where
it would be a situation where you could
go into and and be
born from your grandfather linearly or
whatever in that way but
and then you go back and kill that
person but then time would change but
you could still have done it
because it's not a linearity that's not
multiple universe theory
and yes well you can touch on that but
uh
yeah i mean you're right and you're
right this is
a version a kind of version of the
wheeler multiple universe theory
what i've always shared the aversion to
that
theory of of straight scientists because
the fact that you have to hypothesize an
entire universe springing into being
every time a choice is made seem to me
to violate occam's razor
occam's razor is says hypotheses should
not be multiplied without necessity
and it's simply a faith of modern
science but it's a faith i
share that when we do get the final
explanation
it will be elegant it will be
simple it will have a kind of zen-like
severity um but i entertained ideas like
you're talking about
well i have to confess this this kind of
stuff makes my hair
but i as long as i could preserve
the notion i love the idea of a time
of a of a post-historical time where
people decided not only where they would
live but
when and and people would say well we're
we're moving into the 26th century
and somebody else says well we that's
too hectic for us
we're we're going to hang out in the
22nd
we just can't relate to those 26th
century people you know
and and imagine uh
and surely in the vast universe of
science fiction this has been
done someone has imagined these kinds of
universes where
where going from when to when is no
bigger deal than going from place to
place
but how the paradox is also i was
thinking about it in terms of your idea
of it all
arriving at the same time okay the time
machine is invented and that moment it
all
we break the membrane isn't that kind of
if you go for the grandfather clause
it's kind of a reverse
grandfather clause i mean at that moment
do we have the time to live all those
future centuries in order for it to come
back on us
doesn't it all kind of go blue you know
what i mean that's what i can't
understand there seems to be a paradox
here
you invent the time machine and somehow
the compressed history of development
post-time machine you cause that all to
collapse
and all those generations of people and
empires and space faring and whatever it
is is suddenly just compressed into the
next moment
into the next moment how can that sort
of just sort of cancel it out almost
well i think we may be exploring the
outer the ultimate thule of fuzzy
thinking
here i've been accused of that
an example of this would be talking to a
19th century person
and saying to them did you know that in
the 20th century
anybody with sufficient money can decide
to go
to an airport and fly to bangkok gnome
paris johannesburg jerusalem and be
there
within 12 hours they would say well how
could anyone
live in a world like that everybody will
just be going everywhere everything will
be so chaotic and confu
well it turns out it costs so much that
not everybody is everywhere they want to
be
all the time but but ideally and i think
our the cultural ideal is to make it
cost
less and less that we actually accept
this idea that everybody should be able
to be
anywhere they want and a future society
may accept the idea that people should
have the right to be any when
they want
[Music]
you